hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that made possible uh a
wonderful achievement it is uh uh quang
liam lev versus gukesh and you guys
already know by now that uh broke 2700
and he is the third or rather fourth
youngest ever to achieve such a feat but
we are going to discuss this after we
check out the game uh what we are
interested in how he did this because uh
quang gimli is an incredibly strong
grandmaster he is over 2700 for quite
quite some time now he's very
established and uh well crossing this
barrier uh by being such a such a strong
player is definitely something to to
check out uh and the game is really
really awesome so let's dive straight
into it and then we're going to discuss
a little bit more so here uh le opens
with c4 he goes for the english opening
we have e6 knight to c3 d5 now uh the
ashing core defense but d4 and
transposing into the queen's gambit
declined knight to f6 we have c captures
on d5 e captures on the e5 and now
bishop to g5 nicely developing the
bishop and now bishop to b4 here the
absolute main line is bishop to e7 but
you can't really expect to be the
grandmaster of
last level uh you know playing
only main lines so bishop to b for this
is uh far trickier and now point to e3
uh we have h6 challenging the bishop
asking do you want to capture or do you
want to go back and then i further
harass the bishop bishop to h4 g5 now
bishop to g3 and not a nice knight to e4
with uh pressure on the c3 knight so
rook to c1 defending and now we have h5
uh just uh preparing to trap the bishop
uh h4 will do so uh because after bishop
to e5 f6 uh and there is no more uh
square for this bishop to retreat to so
f3 uh you could also play h3 seems like
it's possible because you can hide the
bishop but then we just trade everything
and it's just a
very very uh weird position to have with
white with the the pawn structure being
so shattered uh you would not have a
good time playing this so instead after
h5
we have f3 uh forcing the knight to move
knight captures on g3h captures and now
just a nice c6 defending the pawn on d5
and here white can't really be too happy
with his position black is the one
dictating the tone of the battle uh but
uh you know uh let's say this this is
perfectly fine so bishop to d3 uh and
now there is one game where bishop to d6
was played also bishop to e6 is a known
move
it's a rather from a famous game uh
yanni pomena she had this position
against the reasons in 2018 in the
marquette memorial uh nipple won this
game after this bishop to e6 idea
but here we have knight to d7 and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
le goes about this he pushes g4 makes
sense of course the pawn cannot capture
the rook would hang so the pawn is
advanced to h4 and now g3 further
challenging this structure but now queen
to e7 glucose says but your king is
still in the center of the board so king
to d2 defending the pawn this way and at
some point we are hoping to bring our
king to b1 and sort of artificially
castle knight to b6 and now pawn to a3
pushing the bishop back bishop to d6
going after the pawn here but now just g
captures on h4 we have g captures and
pawn to f4 and you can see that white
has a very nice control of the center
here with the pawns however he does have
a backwards e3 pawn and he already gave
gokash a past h pawn so bishop to d7
goku is now ready to castle queen side
and queen to f3 uh defending the pawn uh
and now of course we want to hide our
king all the way to b1 we have queen
side castles and here comes ponte f5 now
interestingly uh this seems like uh
glucose blundered the
uh the d5 pawn but it's actually
beautiful what happens if you if you
capture this pawn if you go for the pawn
yes okay the rook controls the c file
but after knight captures and queen
captures there's the bishop to be for
check you sacrifice the bishop and after
or you don't but it doesn't really
matter but after captures and captures
with check that there is no good move
with the king if you go to a light
square d1 or
or e2 we just pick up this pawn with
check and we pick up the white queen so
that's out of the question and another
thing if you block with the rook it's
not much better we can just pick up a
pawn and once the rook blocks again or
or even the visual blocks we're still
just gonna give up the queen for the
rook we've removed the rook so the sea
pawn is no longer pinned and once the
king captures we pick up the queen and
now we're we're up the exchange and just
you know have a completely winning
position the past pawns are
you know everywhere uh this is
completely winning for wooker so that's
his idea he did not blunder upon here if
you guys are wondering so here we have
f5 now preparing further pushing of the
pawns with the g5 and g6 uh king the b8
uh you know just for good measure
getting rid of that king from the c file
and not knight to h3 we have c5 very
principled move by gookash also the
absolute strongest con you know
if you ask the engine and it makes sense
the white king is in the center of the
board it makes sense to open up the
center but now f6 attacking the queen
queen to f8 and now pawn to g5 so at
some point uh of course uh lei is hoping
to push g6 f captures and then f7 and
then he's extremely close to promotion
so rook to g8 stopping g6 for the moment
and the king the c2 now um
we have time to hide our king all the
way to b1
see captures on the 4e captures and rook
to c8 but now just king to b1
and even though this is by far the
strongest move white can play and you
definitely should play this uh black's
position is still much much better but
only if you find that one move that
actually gives black the advantage
where you can even hope to push this for
a win so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this uh wonderful
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
and you have to find it if you want to
become the the fourth youngest 2700
grand master ever
so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the bishop grab but not this one and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is bishop captures an a3 bishop
captures an h3 is also interesting as
you remove the defender of the g5 pawn
but it is not nearly as impressive as
bishop captures on a3 and the problem
here is that the bishop cannot be
captured it's just a free pawn if you
capture the bishop then queen captures
an a3 and now you have problems your
knight is hanging here the knight is
coming to a4 with some checkmating
threats for example if let's say knight
a2 we're gonna play knight a4 threat and
checkmate and once the white queen helps
out with the defense of this check queen
back to d2 we can just play rook
captures on c1 and that's it now we win
our material back if queen captures
we're gonna
capture the bishop here if the rook
captures then we pick up the knight on
h3 so there really isn't um all that
much you can't do and of course if the
knight captures the knight the c3 check
is just a game over king to c2 you are
getting checkmated bishop here knight to
b3 bishop captures king
king captures on c3 and now a nice
discovery will be checkmate so uh it's
uh not possible to capture this bishop
and uh you have to figure out what to
play here you're down a pawn and
what do you have to show for it uh well
here we have knight captures and uh
knight captures on d5 would be the way
to go but here let played knight to b5
since this is a classical game uh we
should discuss what happens if knight
captures on d5 it seems like uh it seems
like it's great but still glucose would
have uh rook captures on c1 rook
captures and after knight captures and
queen captures bishop to e6 and okay uh
you won't back your pawn but the the
bishops are very very strong you can't
play something like uh queen e5 check to
try and push the pawn because we just
moved the bishop back and attacked the
queen
so it's uh definitely playable but it
would be black who would have the
advantage here but still with these
pawns so so close to the uh promotion
promotion rank uh it would be very very
interesting uh but in the actual game
knight the b5 was played in that knight
captures and d5 and now okay bishop
captures on b5 rook captures on c8 first
queen captures in the bishop captures on
b5 but not just the bishop back to d6
the glucose is now up upon and la has to
figure out how to
make something out of this so he goes
back bishop to d3 he wants to play g6 to
give up a pawn and start advancing the f
pawn we have queen to d7 and of course
he goes for it pawn to g6 f captures on
g6 and now okay you could push right
away but he first prepares at knights
the g5 the f7 square now nicely
protected by the knight and by the queen
uh queen to a4 a very tricky idea uh
point is that if you play something
weird you're gonna get checkmated um
if you try something like rook the c1 uh
it does kind of make sense but um uh
well
it actually could be played uh because
if the d4 pawn is captured uh
it it it it's perfectly fine for example
f7 attacks the rook rook to c8 now we
can capture here rook captures knight
captures and knight the e6 now attacks
the queen and the guards the queening
square and it would be very very
interesting if if this happened but
still nothing uh all that great it would
be the best hope to save the game
actually for example queen e5 we win the
bishop bishop captures and f8 knight
captures and white is up a bishop but
black is up four pawns so if anything it
would still be goku's playing for the
win here regardless of him being down
down a piece uh but in the game uh
rusted with knight stays it's a move you
definitely want to play as it guards the
queening square but here it is just too
quick uh because now we have rook to c8
and now uh
things can go very very uh bad for white
uh so here queen to d1 offering a queen
trade and the glucose goes back queen to
d7 uh even though uh the queen trade is
winning but um it's uh for example h3
you will get your pawn to h2 uh f7 pawn
to h2 uh it's very very uh
tricky to play this but let's say bishop
captures on g6 rook to h8 now once this
row comes to h1 because you have to put
it here to prevent promotion
this rook is out of the game
basically forever so
that's one way to do it but bookish has
a different idea uh queen to d7 uh we
have queen the g4 now defending the
knight and now knight the c4 and here uh
white is white is just dead lost
especially if you if you play something
weird let's say you try something like
rook to f1 you want to start pushing
your pawn
you just get checkmated knight d2 check
the rook controls the c file you have to
go to a2 or a1 doesn't really matter
queen to a4 will be checkmate so that's
what gurkish
has in store
but after bishop captures on c4 yes
you've eliminated a very strong attacker
but d captures on c4 what is there for
white to play
uh rook captures on h4 violet but now
comes c3 or just opening up the the
white king b captures now queen to b5
with king the c2 and the king hunter
officially begins queen to a4 with czech
king to d2 now queen to a2 with check
and it doesn't matter where the white
king goes if you go up the board then
queen to c4 check king to e4 and now
queen to c6 with check the five queen
captures on c3 and good luck surviving
this there's really nothing you can play
uh once you make a move uh pretty much
anything just wins queen e1 now you can
block with the queen because the rook
hangs on h4 and if you go king to d3
then rook to c3 will be checkmate so
that doesn't work going up the board so
here instead we have king to d1
but now queen to b3 with czech king the
e2 and rook to e8 there's no way to save
the knight so you have to try something
f7 by le now rook captures on e6 king to
d2 and now even king the c7 just for
good measure you don't have to play it
because the bishop covers the queening
square uh but um you know just making
the king a little bit safer you don't
want to blunder the game once you're
this close to becoming the fourth
youngest 2700 player ever so rook to h7
now comes queen to b2 with check king to
d3 and queen to b1 with check king to d2
now comes queen to e1 with chuck king to
c2 and rook to e2 with check king b3
here queen to be one check and he was in
this position animal 49 that uh
that kwang lim resigned the game uh as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
if you go to a4 then just rook a2 is
checkmate and if you go uh
what else is there king to c4 then it's
a very quick checkmate b5 check king to
d5 queen b3 check only move c4 and queen
captures and c4 will be checkmate so
really really uh awesome stuff uh now
there is something that i've um
i mentioned in the beginning of the
video uh chess base india uh
published this uh on twitter they said
uh uh
becomes the youngest indian sixth
overall and third youngest in the world
to cross twenty seven hundred uh which
isn't really true as magnus carlsen
tweeted that he's actually the fourth
youngest because magnus carlsen uh when
he was 15 years old that was in 2006 uh
he he played a tournament and during the
tournament he crossed the 2700 barrier
uh only it wasn't really uh recorded
because in in 2006 live ratings wasn't
really a thing it was you know only only
if you actually
at the end of the month once uh fiji
publishes the official ratings then it
was considered something but
magnus did break 2700 uh when he was 15
years old a mid tournament but he did
not uh finish the tournament uh you know
in in
on a high note uh so he uh dropped below
at at the end of the tournament but yeah
if you guys uh uh just uh you know uh
straighten this out as magnus uh
published it uh himself uh on twitter as
as a reply to chess-based india's tweet
uh but here are the uh current world
rankings these are the only 2700 players
in the world currently on this day that
i'm making this on the 18th of july uh
so here you can see that gurkish is now
number 33 in the world he won 20
points in classical rating so he's
2703.9 on the live rating list so this
is not the official rating these are the
live ratings if it stays like this until
the end of the month then fide will
upgrade his rating to a new rating so i
think this is something that's a bit a
bit obsolete because no one really looks
at the ratings uh you know on a monthly
basis i mean live ratings is i mean we
use live ratings everywhere so making it
a monthly thing i don't think uh really
suits um uh the needs of
2022 uh but okay i'm sure fidei knows
what they are doing uh but yeah as you
can see uh there are 30 or rather 36 uh
2700 players and only two 2 800 players
that is magnus carlsen and dingler and
yanipong nishi also very very close
after his brilliant performance in
defeating candidates tournament you can
see that he won 26.4 points that is the
the absolute most anyone uh you know for
from the 2700s club gained lucas being
very close with 19.9 points uh but yeah
i just wanted to share that with you
guys so yeah incredible game incredible
achievement you know just with the black
pieces destroying uh 2700 grand master
with uh uh you know not going for the
main lines uh uh you know nibbling on
the on the sidelines but it was enough
to confuse le and get to this beautiful
victory uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank barbara nugman of mango pink
alessandra igor bello paul hinomund and
alan lavrish for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world the croatia granchester
starts tomorrow today is the opening
ceremony but it starts tomorrow
so uh thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day